[تصفيق]
رياح سياسيه تهب باتجاه مصلحه
الديمقراطيين في ولايه كنزس الامريكيه
اعطتهم امالا بازاله الصبغه الجمهوريه
الحمراء عنها للمره الثانيه على الاقل
بمنصب الحاكم
فالولايه الغربيه ورغم تصويتها مرتين
للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب الا ان
الحاكمه الديمقراطيه لوراكيلي انتزعت فوزا
صعبا فيها قبل اربع سنوات حلم الولايات
الثانيه تبنيه كاليك غيرها من المرشحين
الديمقراطيين على قضيه الاجهاض لا سيما
اننا خبيزس رفضوا باغلبيه ساحقه في اغسطس
الماضي ازاله الحمايه الدستوريه للولايه
لحقوق الاجهاض
على الجانب الجمهوري طموح حذرا بتخليص
الولايه من الديمقراطيين واعادتها لصفهم
من خلال مرشحهم المدعي العام داريكشميد
وعوده قائمه على الدفاع عن الحريه الدينيه
ومحاربه الجريمه ومعارضه الاجهاض وفي ظهره
دعم قوي من الرئيس السابق لا سيما ان
الانتخابات النصفيه لهذا العام بيئه اقل
احتضانا نسبيا للمحافظين
على طويله المنافسه في مفارقه غريبه ففي
قلبي حمله الحاكمه الديمقراطيه صوره
جمعتها بالرئيس السابق بالاشهر الاولى من
جاء حتى كورونا لتؤكد من خلالها وضع
السياسه الحزبيه جانبا للتركيز على الانسب
لكانزا
هذا هو يحاول ترامب تحفيز قاعدته
الانتخابيه والحفاظ عليها طبعا باصوات
كنزس السته بالمجمع الانتخابي في حال
ترشحه الانتخابات الرئاسه مع الاخذ
بالاعتبار ان الولايه تميل الى الجمهوريين
بشكل كبير ولم تصوت لديمقراطي في البيت
الابيض منذ عام 1964